we have made the adjustment from
offensive lineman to running backs here
on this wednesday edition of pft live at
the scouting combine we saw and heard a
little bit from our next guest while he
was over at the podium earlier he's with
us now jk dobbins ohio state running
back great to see you buddy how's your
experience in indianapolis so far it's
definitely a blessing um
it's great to be around all these great
players and the nfl teams and you know
it's just something you dream of as a
kid
how much testosterone takes over when
you guys are together for the first time
and you're seeing guys that maybe you've
never met guys you've seen on the field
on other teams what what's what's that
emotion like when you're around these
guys you're eventually going to be
competing with the nfl level yeah it's
definitely a different feeling you know
it's kind of like you trying to fill
everyone out and you know you
most people think they're the best one
at their position or
even the best person here so you know
definitely a great a great place to be
though well if you're trying to sell me
as a coach a gm whoever on why i should
take you why you're the best running
back in this class what does jk dobbins
have to say for himself in response to
that question you know
uh i think my um film speaks for herself
you know
all the vision i have the explosion is
exposing this and then you know all that
stuff but i'm a great leader you know
and i feel like when our team is on the
on the field with me i'm gonna make
every single player around me better you
know and i think that separates me from
most guys how do you do that do you do
it by example do about do you do it
vocally how what is your leadership
style uh i can do it both ways vocally
and
by my actions you know and i think a lot
of the guys on my team saw that with my
actions and then if a guy needed to call
me
they know i'm there as well and if i
needed to get on someone's uh tail i'm
definitely going to do that too you said
earlier over at the podium you're not
going to be doing any of the workouts
because you're recovering from the ankle
injury that was the game against clemson
where that was sustained how far do you
think you are away from getting back to
100 percent uh i'm definitely close to
being 100 and then
the the really the most important thing
that has me uh iffy about friday is my
hamstring i've never had a hamstring
injury before in my life so that's
definitely an injury that i just you
know had
and i'm trying to work through it i've
never had it before but if i'm ready to
go friday i'll definitely run
even with the
the ankle i mean i thought the ankle was
still going to take some more time to
get back to 100 but you still go ahead
and give it a shot i think it's about 95
right now
um what have you been able to do by way
of training since you're dealing with
the ankle and now the hamstring uh
really just being smart about it and you
know just figuring out ways to keep
getting better and getting faster even
with the ankle you like i had to rest a
few weeks for the ankle like two weeks
but whenever it's time to go i'm hitting
it hard because i mean that i like to
work hard you know so that's
nothing hard for me to do texas guy got
recruited to ohio state had to be so
hard to say no to all those schools in
texas what is it that caused you decide
to go to columbus instead of staying
home uh you know
columbus is a special place you know and
uh i definitely knew that if i go there
i'm gonna get developed as a man as a
football player you know the academics
are good there as well
and it's just a special place i knew
that i was going to be able to play in
big games and that's that was a big
thing for me as well who is it that
helped you develop the most as a man
when you were at ohio state uh tony
alford running backs coach
how how did he go about doing it give me
give me an example of what he did to
help you grow and develop you know just
when i was a freshman
uh you know i i don't know what i'm
getting into you know and i want to
start as a true freshman you know so i
got i started i started as a true
freshman and i run for 181 yards in my
first game ever
and coach alfred is there to let me know
that that's just that's nothing you know
let's keep going you know we got a lot
more things to do in your career here so
that definitely helped me grow as a
person as a as a man
and you know just off the field things
like
family things and you know one day i'll
eventually have kids and he showed me
the right way to you know take care of
my kids and my family
what guys from ohio state who are now in
the nfl have been giving you advice on
what to expect through this process and
once you get into the league yeah
definitely uh
my best friend is like it's terry mc
mclaren boy he was great last year my
goodness
unbelievable i knew he was going to be a
lot of people were like shocked when
they when he came out and started doing
all this crazy stuff but i knew
for a fact that he was going to be great
because he works he works so hard you
know and keeps his faith in god and i
knew he was going to be a special player
what kind of advice is he giving you you
know just stay the course you know stay
focused you know enjoy the process you
know and just just do your best keep
working hard when was the moment
jk that you knew
you had what it takes to make it to the
nfl what was it in a game a practice
what was it when that light went off for
you that this is my destiny uh
i like to say uh you know in high school
when i started you know getting
developed and you know started
being getting bigger and stronger and
faster you know i kind of saw myself you
know
playing nfl you know if it was this year
or maybe next year you know
or ever i knew i was going to play an
nfl because i just worked so hard and i
wasn't going to be denied
who do you model your game after
definitely christian mccaffrey my team
didn't really put me in a slight
receiver like that but i definitely can
catch the ball a lot so i definitely see
myself as him a player like him you know
and he runs tough can make people miss
and take the distance just just like me
what was the name of your high school in
texas lagrange all right we got some
lagrange highlights
of jk dobbins right here ready to go
uh you remember this one oh my gosh
there's a blur i guess that's you yeah
and he's gone he's loose as paul allen
would say
yeah you got the lsu uniforms i'm
surprised you didn't go to baton rouge
yeah yeah definitely close
uh you know it's funny i see these high
school highlights and i see guys that
they think have an angle
there's no angle there's never an angle
when you get that kind of speed
was there a moment when you got to ohio
state either on the practice field or
against an opponent where
it was basically welcome to this level
this isn't high school anymore uh yeah
definitely you know uh
my freshman year coming in you got guys
like nick bosa sam hubbard you know
taekwon lewis you got jerome baker you
got denzel award
those guys are on the defense and i was
practicing against those guys and you
know those are those are not bad
football players and it was definitely
like oh they can run they can run a
little faster you know and they can
they're a little bigger so but it was
definitely a great experience though you
know it's funny we talk all the time
about the sec and how competing in the
sec gets guys ready for the nfl ohio
state is like a mini sec when you think
of all the nfl players that come out of
that program and how like nick boson
scary he ran by us during the playoff
game and he wasn't even in pads and i
was scared i mean i can't imagine
practicing against a guy like that who
hit you the hardest at ohio state hit me
the hardest uh
drone baker you know jerome baker uh he
definitely uh hit me the hardest he was
definitely a good hitter you know and um
you know
chase tries to hit me but chase
i try to get him uh you know on the
slick side you know you came up at a
time when
the nfl running back position really
changed and the the contracts aren't as
big
that you've got two and three guys on a
roster not one workhorse who gets the
ball 30 times a game and it seems like
the nfl had been de-emphasizing the
running back position but now it kind of
feels like it's swinging back the other
way where do you sense the running back
position is in the nfl i think it's uh
one of the most important positions on
the team because we do everything from
passing i mean from catching the ball
out of the backfield to blocking to
running you know and we just
i think we do a lot of everything you
know and that helps the team a lot and
if you look at the teams that you know
won the super bowl like the chiefs they
had a great running game and a guy that
could catch the ball out of the
backfield and he won the game and look
at the tennessee titans they went pretty
far with a guy that was workhorse you
know so i honestly think the running
back position
i don't think it's you know
devalue
between
blocking and obviously picking up
blitzes is critical at the nfl level
between that and pass catching which
skill is better do you think for jk for
me uh definitely uh catching the ball
out of the backfield you know blocking
i'm pretty good at it but i definitely
can work on it you know because it's
something that doesn't come naturally
you definitely have to work on it
because you know in high school you
never have to you know you're getting
the ball a lot in high school so getting
to college you have to work on that and
um what do you do specifically to work
on blocking you know uh definitely we
have we have a
pad on the wall at ohio state called the
difference board definitely do that to
you know get my hand placement right you
know just and work on footwork
techniques you know to finish my blocks
around my feet
how much of it is just sheer will or how
much of it is consciously thinking about
what you need to do
oh yeah blocking you definitely have to
mentally be there because
it's different you know it's definitely
different for a running back but
honestly you want to do it you have to
want to do it well my big takeaway is
there is a skill set in jk dobbins that
maybe we didn't get to fully appreciate
at the college level that someone is
going to benefit from if they decide to
throw the ball to jk dobbins out of the
back field and you know there's only
three members of the 1 000 yard rushing
and receiving club christian mccaffrey
is the newest one we could be looking at
number four we'll see how it plays out
we wish you all the best as you get
healthy have a great workout if you're
able to do it have a great pro day have
a great draft day and we look forward to
seeing the nfl jk sir thank you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports